Now, we know how easy it is to transform a function in a lot of different ways.
We can make a graph move to the left, we can make it move to the right. We can
make it move up, and we can make it move down, too. We can even flip it upside
down, amazing. Now, we know that this kind of flipping is called a reflection
in the x-axis since the x-axis is the line that we're flipping the graph
across. However, we have this other axis, too, the y-axis. What do you think a
reflection in the y-axis would look like? And how do we make that happen in our
equation for a function? The function that we were just looking at and that I
was just transforming is this black one right here, f of x equals the square
root of x. Now, graphs A and B here are graphs of different functions,
functions that are different transformations of this original function. Which
one represents this function reflected in the x-axis? And which one, for
instance this function, reflected in the y-axis? Please fill in A or B in each
of these boxes.